Bryan Behrenshausen interviewing Tony Wasserman for the
FOSSDA project.
Tony, thanks so much for doing this.
Really appreciate it.
Absolutely.
I want to start just to talk
about your early academic pursuits, I guess,
because I'm trying to paint a picture
of what gets a person attracted to
open source and how different people find
their ways into computer science and open
source.
And so I want to talk about
about where you went to college and
what you went to college for.
I think you were a double major,
is that right?
It's true.
Yeah.
Tell me a little bit about where
you went to school and what you
went to school for.
So I went to Cal, University of
California, Berkeley.
I went there from Coral Gables, Florida
of all places.
So I have my parents to thank
for letting me go all the way
across the country.
And it was really because I think
my father always wanted to move to
California and didn't.
And so it seemed like the place
to go.
So I did a double major in
math and physics at Berkeley, and I
took my first computing course as a
junior at Cal.
And it was very quickly obvious to
me that I was much better at
programming and computing than I was at
math or physics.
And so having gone through Berkeley, I
then went to graduate school at University
of Wisconsin, Madison.
And my original thought was that I
would go for a master's degree, but
they gave me money and made me
an RA and encouraged me to stay.
So eventually I got a doctorate in,
of all things, artificial intelligence.
Yeah.
I want to talk about that a
little bit then too.
Yeah.
So that was very early in the
AI days during the initial wave of
excitement, which then went to sleep for
50 years.
So that was my academic education and
coming out.
I think the two things that stuck
with me from my graduate school was
one, writing interactive programs because the technology
at the time was really primitive.
Rolls of teletype paper that printed 10
uppercase characters per second and clattered as
it did it.
So when you put this in front
of somebody who was unfamiliar with computers,
as I had to do for my
research, it was really quite an interesting
exercise and taught me a lot at
this very, very early stage of computing
about user experiences and human computer interaction.
And And I did a little bit
more work on that over the years.
So that was one thing that I
came away with.
And the other thing that I came
away with was how to architect large
software systems, because my dissertation program got
to be quite large and being able
to read all this code after you've
you've written it for years.
And even if it's your own code,
being able to do all these things
that we now take for granted in
software engineering levels of abstraction and modularization.
I went back and I looked at
this 50-plus-year-old code not too long ago,
and it was written in ALGOL.
I've only ever heard of that language.
I don't think I've ever even seen
it.
ALGOL is wonderful.
I mean, it was perfect for these
stack architectures machines.
And ALGOL predates Fortran, actually.
Not by much, but it does.
Yeah.
And it was much more of an
international effort.
So it was great.
And I did this on a Burroughs
computer.
You've probably never heard of Burroughs computers
either.
But at the time, it was IBM
and the seven dwarfs, RCA and General
Electric and Honeywell and Burroughs and UNIVAC
and Control Data.
That's six.
That's not bad.
There's a seventh.
Oh, scientific data systems.
So that's seven.
Those are the seven dwarfs.
And IBM had like 70% market share.
But that was where I did my
work, and I learned about how to
design large systems.
Yeah.
So I want to...
That's fascinating.
I want to back up a little
bit, just talk about that crossroads that
you found yourself at.
You sort of glossed over something I
think is all too common for folks
in academe.
And that is, you had a set
of interests that led you into certain
fields, in this case, math and physics.
And then there was something, and you
said, because you were better at it.
But I would venture to say that
there's probably a lot of things you're
good at or better at than math
and physics that you didn't go into.
So I guess my question is twofold.
One, what do you think it was
about you as a person that initially
got started, math and physics?
What about your personality led you to
those fields?
And then can you remember the moment
where you realized like, oh, this is
where I'm meant to go?
Do you have any memories?
A little bit.
I mean, from the time that I
was very young, I was good at
arithmetic and mathematics and memory numbers, all
things numerical.
And so it seemed like the natural
direction.
And when you're in elementary school or
middle school or high school, there are
certain things that you don't have to
worry at all.
You just got it made.
If you're at that level.
And so it always seemed to me
that my ability in mathematics was so
natural, and that was reinforced by SAT
scores and high school grades and all
those kinds of things.
So when it came time to pick
a major, it wasn't as much as
I'm interested in history, for example.
I see.
And actually took some history courses at
Cal.
It wasn't what I was going to
do with my life.
I always had the impression that you
could make a living at mathematics.
And I guess that's true still.
Yeah, I assume so.
But I also assume that when you
were in school, in primary school,
you didn't have access to computers, right?
You wouldn't have known that you had
an affinity for computational mathematics or computer
science or computer hardware in general, because
your first exposure to them was probably
at the university level.
Right.
That's correct.
Because when I was seven years old,
there was a national election, and they
had the UNIVAC brain.
Yes, I remember.
Well, I've seen the footage.
Predicting the outcome of the election.
And that was kind of my first
introduction to computing, and and they made
it seem so mystical.
It was kind of there in the
back of my mind.
But computing really was not an issue
for people, certainly not until the late
1950s, when banks and airlines and the
like began using them for a lot
of their routine things.
Of course, computers were used in the
defense and military areas, but that was
not an area that I knew anything
about, nor did I have any interest
in.
So I've done a PhD as well,
and in my field in
communication studies, the dissertation involves essentially like
the production of a large monograph, essentially
like a book-length monograph.
But from what I understand, you you
were saying earlier, your dissertation project involved,
I'm sure, a significant amount of writing,
but also building a program.
Is that right?
That's right.
I mean, you know,
my dissertation runs 200 some odd pages.
I think I have a digital copy
of it on this machine somewhere.
But because it was systems-oriented, you had
to build something and demonstrate it.
So the code was somewhere above 10,000
lines.
I don't remember the exact count, but
it was a fair amount of code.
And what specific dissertation or what specific
problem was
your dissertation trying to figure out?
What were you tackling?
The title of the dissertation
was Achievement of Skill and Generality in
an Artificial Intelligence Program, which is a
problem that exists to this day.
What do they call Alexa add-ons, right?
They call them skills.
You download skills for your Alexa, right?
We don't have any listening devices in
my house.
I don't either.
Except for this.
One of the things that strikes me
as particularly interesting about the OpenAI and
the GPT-4 and BARD technologies is that
they do cover, they have one skill
that they're really, really good at, which
is information retrieval and compression and restatement.
But it works across a wide variety
of domains.
Because the other day, for example, I
asked BARD to help me plan a
couple of days of sightseeing on an
upcoming trip.
And it gave me a very nice
list of suggestions.
At one o'clock in the afternoon, do
this.
At three o'clock in the afternoon, do
that.
Go have tapas at this place at
this time.
It was pretty impressive.
What was your dissertation specifically?
What did your program do with regard
to AI?
It was the world's best bridge bidding
program.
Okay.
Because at the time, there was, of
course, checkers, which was very early and
not not such a huge problem to
build a skillful program.
But people were starting to work on
chess, of course, at that time.
And chess is a combinatorially difficult problem.
And it turns out that bridge the
same way, the number of hands that
can be dealt and the division of
them among multiple players, turns out that
it's hard.
And the technology that I used, there
were two or three technologies, but what
I used was rule-based.
So that you had to, there there
are ways, standard ways to evaluate the
cards in your hand and to interpret
the bids that your partner makes to
help you come up with a final
bid or maybe seat to the opposition,
the contract that's to be made.
Now, later on, after I had left
the university, I did, in fact, work
with one other person and we built
the play of the hand part and
it played quite well.
And the fascinating thing about it is
that we found somebody who wanted to
manufacture a box, right?
So there's an item called the Goran
Bridge Master.
And you can find them, they're very
scarce, but on bidding sites, you can
find them.
And I have one that's kind of
unopened, untouched.
But the asking price was $350, which
is, you know, it limited the appeal.
Oh, that was 1970s dollars, $350, 1970s
dollars, not the cost of the one
from the internet that you bought.
Right.
Ah, gotcha.
Yeah, that limits your audience a little
bit.
Yep.
Yeah, a little bit prohibitive.
And so, and of course, they didn't
spend as much money as they might
have on marketing.
So who knows?
There was no social media to get
the word out.
So we might have had a different
outcome in a modern era with a
different price point and a different marketing
message, but that's something we'll never know.
Yeah, right.
So when then did
you first encounter the idea of open
source software?
So I think it came about in
two ways.
The first was that I was aware
of the things like IBM Share and
Guide, which were, you know, these annual
meetings where the company would talk about
its future plans, and people brought software
to share.
And the mentality at the time was
very, very different.
That is, it's the hardware that's expensive,
and the software isn't worth anything.
You know, here's my routine to perform
this calculation.
Here's this one to compute some trajectory,
you know, share and share alike.
And so that was something I knew
about.
I didn't have any particular use for
it at the time.
But then when UNIX came in the
1970s, I was on the faculty at
UC San Francisco, and then I was
also a lecturer at Berkeley, where I
taught data structures and operating systems and
things like that.
And Berkeley at the time got one
of the earliest PDP 1170, well, I
think it was a 45 originally, that
ran at least part of the day
it ran UNIX.
And then very quickly, they had machines
that ran UNIX all the time.
And Berkeley received a grant from the
United States Department of of Defense that
involved enhancing AT&T UNIX.
So Berkeley got the source code to
AT&T UNIX.
And they made a bunch of changes,
virtual memory being the one that is
perhaps the most significant.
They made this all run on a
digital equipment corporation, VAX 11780, and distributed
it.
And the license from AT&T was a
commercial license.
But in the, in the academic setting,
with government money being spent, then then
the license was different.
And so they created the BSD license.
Nobody used the term open source software
at that point.
It was the BSD license.
And so anybody could obtain the software,
or you could go spend $43,000 with
AT&T to get the commercial one.
And, you know, there's a history here
of different hardware vendors, either supporting the
AT&T version of the UNIX or the
modified Berkeley version of UNIX.
But, but the, the Berkeley version certainly
won out in academia because the price
was right.
And so we got to a point
where almost every computer science department had
a a VAX and ran UNIX and
students learned a lot of their computing
on UNIX.
Things like the VI editor were developed
by Bill Joy at, at Berkeley.
And, you know, he had a different
version of UNIX of, I'm sorry, VI
every day.
So you could, yes, it was really
a model for the kind of rinse,
lather and repeat.
So it was a, it was a
very agile approach to building the software
before anybody used the term agile to
describe the process.
So, so that's, you know, that's the
origin of VI.
And so that, what that led to,
I was working on a project in,
at UC San Francisco, project was called
user software engineering.
And the term was coined because software
engineering was the big thing, right?
Top down design and this kind of
thing.
And I said, well, you know, if
you're building interactive systems, people don't really
care about how your system is architected.
So, so we were doing what I
call the outside in engineering.
So getting, getting user interface right.
And if you think about this the
user interface in that era, as I
said before, was extremely primitive.
We had moved on from TTY terminals
to 24 by 80 visual displays that
looked like a TV set with a
keyboard.
They were monochrome, you know, black on
white was really sophisticated.
Green on black was more common.
And there were, there were thousands of
different manufacturers of these terminals.
And so one of the things that
they had to do in Unix was
to create a library that was dependent
on the characteristics of each terminal.
This was a library called Curses, which
is a funny, funny name for it.
Anyway, to come back to the UCSF
situation, we were doing UCSF, we're doing
user software engineering.
And so we were building tools to
support this method, because to me, you
can have a method for building software,
but tools exist to support a method.
So since most of the applications we
were concerned with at the time were
conversational access to databases, we built a
database system.
And this was at a very early
stage, building a relational database system.
You know, the research papers were written
in 1970.
And the first relational database systems showed
up at the end of the 1970s.
System R, IBM Research, and Ingress at
Berkeley, and a couple of others.
So we built a tool for user
interface prototyping.
And we built a database management system,
and we made them available.
And we made them available under a
BSD license.
So we licensed the people who licensed
the software from the University of California,
San Francisco, or from the regents of
the University of California, they could have
it and use it.
And we got a reasonably good reaction
to it, which led us forward, because
people came and said, well, who's going
to support all of this stuff?
Yes, the universities were fine, they would
play with it.
But once somebody in companies wanted it,
then, you know, the IT manager said,
well, you know, who's going to support,
we can't use this unless there's support
for it.
And back to us and say, well,
who's going to support it?
And we said, okay, we'll do it.
And so that led to our starting
a company.
And the products that we had, the
things that we built at UCSF were
foundations for the computer aided software engineering
tools that we built.
They ran on some workstations and all
of the other engineering workstations of that
era.
And most of the software we built
in the company was proprietary.
But those pieces that we had licensed
from the University of California, we put
a clause in our license agreement that
talked about this particular part of the
software that was part of what we
were distributing.
So we were distributing open source software
in 1980.
Yeah, before that even existed.
Right, right.
Exactly.
And, and, you know, Berkeley Unix was
being distributed the same way.
So there was this community around it.
And Ingress at Berkeley was also distributed
under a BSD license.
And Mike Stonebraker, who was the lead
on that project, also started a company
called Relational Technology initially.
And it was just down the road
from campus in Berkeley.
But they were quite successful with Relational
Technology, which became Ingress, which eventually got
acquired by somebody, I don't know.
And what was the name of your
company again?
Interactive Development Environments, IDE.
And the product was called Software Through
Pictures.
Ah, okay.
So we were one of the first
products to include open source software.
I think we were second.
I think Sun Microsystems was first.
Okay.
Sun basically took Berkeley Unix, they hired
Bill Joy and other people from Berkeley.
And they created Sun OS, which was
a closed operating system.
So, you know, just as our product
was closed at that point, so was
theirs.
And so they were 1982.
And we didn't start IDE until 1983.
And we didn't release anything to paying
users until 1984.
At the very end of 1984, it
actually turned out we did our launch
at a Sun user group meeting on
election day in 1984.
Yeah, yeah.
Wow.
So I'm trying to determine how I
want to ask this follow up question.
So I guess it's twofold.
One, did you ever, did you always
intend to work in the private sector
like that, let alone start a company?
And second, did you ever think that
you would start a company selling software?
You know, by your own admission, when
you got started in the field, the
software was the trivial part.
It was the hardware that was expensive.
Now, here you are, what a decade
later, you're building a business on the
buying and selling of software.
So did you intend to do you
ever?
Did you foresee that path for yourself?
Was that desirable?
Or did did it just kind of
play out that way?
Yeah, I think that it's accurate to
say that it played
out that way.
But I wanted to come back to
something you said a moment ago, software
is not software was not trivial.
I mean, all the software that was
being built in the 1960s broke.
That's why.
That's why NATO sponsored the conferences that
led to software engineering as a discipline,
right?
There was a NATO conference in Garmisch,
Germany at the end of 1968, and
a follow up in Rome at late
in 1969.
And there are these two volumes that
came out of it.
And many of the famous early people
in the software engineering community participated in
this, which in effect, defined software engineering,
and recognized that building software was anything
but trivial.
Maybe I should Yeah, that's I miss
I misspeak when I say that maybe
I should say sort of
economically trivial, right?
Or by your going by what you
were talking about how to earlier like
that it was everybody thought the money
was in the hardware.
The software was just the stuff that
you passed around freely to it was
not as valuable hardware was right.
So.
So it wasn't business on it.
Yeah, but it wasn't until software was
perceived to have value,
that it made sense to have a
business.
So the, the earliest commercial software was
a sorting program in the mid 1960s.
And that was that came about because
in 1964, IBM announced the IBM, the
system 360.
So in in the before that they
had commercial machines that were decimal oriented,
and scientific machines that were binary oriented
to completely different lines of machines.
And so system 360 says, Well, you
know, we're going to do it all.
And oh, by the way, we're going
to build a family of machines from
small to large, that they had less
power than than your mobile phone, but
but but they did go small to
large.
And so somebody said, Well, you know,
all these commercial businesses need a sorting
program.
And it's going to run on all
these IBM 360.
And so that was the start of
the commercial software business in the mid
1960s.
And, and then there were some data
management programs that that came about not
too long thereafter.
Things like total, which nobody's ever heard
of at this at this time, but
it was a big thing in its
time.
And so so the software industry began
to develop in the 1970s.
And that, you know, that opened up
a possibility.
But I think that my switching from
academia to to industry was was driven
by several things.
One is sort of being in the
right place at the right time.
place at the right time.
I mean, the the the energy, the
buzz around Unix, certainly was influential.
And then my early exposure to Sun
Microsystems, because the among the first machines
that were available were available were given
to Berkeley.
And so my students and I had
an opportunity very early on to build
this graphical software that took advantage of
the large bitmap bitmap display, which was
kind of cool at the time, right?
The computer aided design programs had preceded
computer aided software engineering engineering by a
couple of years.
But, you know, you sort of you
put one and one together and say,
hey, we have this unique technology, we
have people who want us to support
it.
We have these ideas about tools for
doing software design.
And, you know, there are a lot
of other people starting companies these days,
and we're at least as smart as
they are.
So we thought.
So off we went.
And the company, we got financial funding,
we were actually IDE was one of
the first hundred dot coms.
So, you know, you think today of
the millions and millions and millions, we
were number 78.
How do you know that number?
Because there's a website called first hundred
dot coms.
And how do they do that?
Like they rank them or they note
them based on when you like incorporated
like your incorporation date or the or
registered you registered the domain name or
what's the.
Yes, it was the domain registration that
triggered it.
So so a company like Symbolics, which
is a LISP machine, an AI oriented
machine.
I think they were number one.
And, you know, who's heard of Symbolics
these days?
Right.
So so it's a question of being
in the right place in the right
time and putting one and one together.
I would say it was fairly opportunistic
because I gave up a tenured faculty
position.
Yeah, that's not easy to leave leave
behind for sure.
Well, you know, we the world was
changing.
And so we were able to build
a company that had a really leading
edge technology and it ran on leading
edge hardware.
We had a very good partnership with
Sun Microsystems because we were one of
their first third party software vendors.
And what the salespeople discovered was that.
When people bought our software, they would
also buy hardware because they would buy
our computer aided software engineering tools and
put it on a Sun workstation and,
you know, equip an engineer that way.
And so the Sun salespeople got the
idea right away.
Gee, we should work with Tony and
with IDE because that's a good way
for us to sell hardware.
Yeah.
So we had access to Sun offices
everywhere.
And there's some very funny stories about
demonstrating our product in China in nineteen
eighty six and in on the Isle
of Capri in Italy or off the
coast in the same time frame.
Getting a machine into these places.
Yeah, that's right.
Especially in the
China and the 80s.
How are you going to commandeer it
for a demo?
Yes.
Yeah.
And physically move it, I would assume.
Right.
Like the you know,
because the stuff was pretty fragile.
Right.
I mean.
Yeah.
I mean, Right.
I mean.
Yeah.
I mean, it was a big display.
Right.
17 inch display.
And yeah, it was a Motorola 68000
processor in there until Sun replaced it
with their own.
So, it with their own.
So, yeah, getting it around was non-trivial.
So, you know, that was fun.
You get to see the world and
do software.
And you had this little bit of
open source software in it.
Yeah.
And so you were doing open source
software before there was open source software,
as open source software, as we established.
When did you first hear people start
to talk about open source, use the
phrase open source software?
Well, what you heard first was free
software.
Because you had RMS, Richard Stallman at
MIT, first was free software.
MIT, who thought that all software should
be free.
And he may still think that.
And so you have, you know, the
GNU project with its C compiler and
some of the tools.
And you had Richard, who was very
adamant about the problem that he was
encountering with a Canon laser printer, because
he had no access to the source
code.
This is.
And so this led to the Free
Software Foundation in the mid 1980s.
And so this notion of free software
was out there.
And while it was absolutely okay with
them, that people made money from software,
the it wasn't really the whole notion
wasn't pitched at companies and suggesting that
they use open source.
So it wasn't really until after the
open source initiative got created, and the
Apache agreement was made with IBM for
Apache to be part of their Java
Enterprise Edition product, that the term open
source began to to get circulated and
used.
So I would say it was right
about the turn of the millennium when,
when I became more of the millennium
when, when I became more aware of
it.
And then by then I had, you
know, IDE had been merged with some
other companies, because our investors thought that
was the thing to do.
And so I left and I joined
a startup, which wasn't going to be
successful.
But I learned Java Enterprise Edition at
that point.
And that got me to my next
job, which was with a great small
company And that got me to my
next job, which was with a great
small company called Bluestone Software.
They were based, they were based in
South Jersey.
Oh, my gosh.
So you don't associate New Jersey with
software.
No, not, not, it's not, it's not
the Silicon Valley of the East, for
sure.
But they were the best Java software
for miles in any direction, including creeping
into Pennsylvania, which wasn't all that far
away.
And so so I ran their West
Coast Development Lab, far away.
Coast Development Lab, and we built tools
that were actually to run on mobile
devices to talk to a Java Enterprise
server.
And we gave away, and we gave
away the code.
devices to talk to a Java Enterprise
server.
And we gave away, and we gave
away the code.
Okay, under the terms of a license,
I'm assuming.
No.
Okay.
So, because by that time,
Bluestone had sold itself to Hewlett Packard.
And so when we wanted to give
away the software, they said, Oh, yeah,
yeah, you can give it away.
You can.
But they had no clue of that
open source at that point, which is
funny, because Hewlett Packard was one of
the true leaders in open source and
in adoption of open source, their group
in Colorado Springs.
Some very well known people in the
open source community were there, Stormy Peters,
who you probably know from her stint
at Microsoft and at GitHub.
Phil Robb, who runs open source for
Ericsson here in the United States.
And several other people, I mean, there
was a really, they were really avant
garde, if you will, when it comes
to They built the whole Fossology lab.
But this other little corner of Hewlett
Packard didn't do open source.
So we gave away the source code,
but it didn't have an open source
license.
So in theory, we retained the copyright
to it.
Actually, in practice, we retained the copyright
Yeah.
So you mentioned a couple names of
folks, you know, from those days.
What do you remember about your early
encounters, I guess, with people in the
open source ecosystem early on when it
was in its genesis?
Well, part of that, of course, is
based on what we mean by genesis.
Yeah, right.
You know, I mean, there are people
who were there at the very beginning,
Bruce Perens, for example, and Brian Bellendorf,
who was at CollabNet.
And I didn't meet them till later.
And because I hadn't really sunk into
that community yet.
But what happened was, in 2004, I
was running product development for another startup
that was not going to be successful.
But you know, 90% of them failed.
So okay.
Yeah, Yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
It wasn't my startup.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And it was two guys who had,
I think, a promising idea.
And they built the company, they built
the product, and the company stuck around
for a little while.
But I didn't.
In 2004, it turns out I went
to the International Conference on Software Engineering
in Edinburgh.
And one of the people that I
ran into there, I've been going to
these international conferences on software engineering since
the very first one in the mid
70s.
So one of the people I met
there was Martin Griss, who I had
known for many years.
He ran the research lab at Hewlett
Packard for a long time.
And then he had just joined the
brand new Carnegie Mellon campus that's in
Silicon Valley, which for people who know
the geography, is on the NASA Ames
Research Park in Mountain View.
So Martin says to me, hey, you
know, we're doing, we're getting this academic
program in software engineering started out here.
Why don't you come around and take
a look.
One thing led to another.
And in 2005, I joined the faculty
there.
And one of the things that came
out of that was that I wanted
to be able to establish a research
program in addition to the course that
I taught.
And so for a research topic, I
picked open source.
Okay.
And not building open source code so
much as evaluation and adoption and use
of open source.
I see.
Okay.
And so, you know, I went off
and started talking to people at the
time.
Microsoft was, of course, totally dominant in
the software industry, both in terms of
the Windows operating system and also with
Microsoft Office Suite.
So you really didn't do much computing
on the desktop without Microsoft.
So one of the first places I
looked was at Microsoft to see what
they were doing.
At the time, Steve Ballmer, who was
their CEO at the time, was saying
things like the open source is a
cancer.
Open source is a communist plot.
You know, here are all these people
in t-shirts hanging out in, you know,
in rooms writing code and sharing it
and giving it away when it has
value.
But it turns out that they had
a guy who was responsible for monitoring
what was going on in open source.
And I met him.
And then he didn't last all that
long.
And then the next person in that
link was Sam Ramji, who has been,
I think, a key part of the
open source community for a long time.
And he's still active.
Anyway, so in addition to that, we
were beginning to see a number of
open source projects pop up.
One of the best known is MySQL,
which started in the mid 90s, 1994.
And we also saw the huge growth
of Linux, which started from 1991.
And Red Hat, your former employer, you
know, started doing Linux in 1994 or
so.
And so there was this momentum started
to build up.
But so these were, you know, things
that were, I think, very influential in
driving the Unix community, or the Linux
community and the open source community.
We began to see conferences.
It was the open source business conference,
which was focused on commercial adoption.
There was the open source think tank,
which was this much smaller meeting, chaired
by Andrew Aitken, who eventually ended up
running the open source business for Wipro,
the Indian services company.
And so, you know, these names keep
reappearing, popping up, yeah, as people move
around.
And so you had, you also had
the wiki movement, there were a number
of different wikis that came about, of
which the best known, of course, is
MediaWiki because of Wikipedia.
So, so there's a challenge that I
formulated at that time, which is how
much can you do with only open
source software?
Okay, so, so OpenOffice was there, right?
It wasn't as compatible with Microsoft Office,
then as it is now.
Of course, LibreOffice also was a fork
from that.
There were early content management systems.
Joomla!
and Drupal.
Drupal, of course, is still around.
Drupal has a huge community, has been
a huge success.
You know, it was actually Dries Voithoudt's
PhD dissertation.
Yes, that's right.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So, so, but what we, so those
are kind of the grassroots of a
lot of open source, and people were
putting open source on a shared repository,
SourceForge.
So SourceForge was the GitHub of its
day.
And again, SourceForge still exists, but
obviously has been dwarfed by the adoption
and widespread use of GitHub.
So, you know, not everything dies, it
just kind of hangs around for a
while.
Yeah, right, right.
Well, then, when did you, when did
you know that you wanted to play
a more
pivotal role in influencing the, in stewarding
open source?
You were, you joined the OSI at
some point, right?
So that was a little later.
Because OSI didn't have affiliate members,
and they didn't have individual members for
a long time.
But in 2005, my first year at
Carnegie Mellon, I organized a conference on
open source software in the Bay Area,
and we got 100 or so people,
and I managed to get some, you
know, luminaries in, in open source, Denise
Cooper was one of our speakers, for
example, and she's certainly very well known
for her long term contributions in open
source.
And so, you know, that was the
thing that told me that this was
what's happening now, that this movement toward
open source was happening, it was happening
slowly.
Because at that time, and maybe for
the next four or five years after
that, there were camps, that there were
people who believed in open source, and
they didn't want to send any money
to Redmond, Washington, or to Redwood Shores,
California, or other places that were homes
to major proprietary software businesses.
And then, of course, you had the
other side, which are the large companies
that said, you know, they believed what
Microsoft said, or they got everything that
they needed from proprietary software, and had
no use for open source.
And the executives in some of those
companies would say, we don't use open
source.
And my answer to them was, you
want to bet?
Yeah.
Yep.
And you know, at that time, you
had the emergence of companies like Black
Duck, which were out there analyzing source
code and looking for open source software
in those larger systems.
And surprise, surprise, there was a lot
of it out there.
And, of course, Black Duck has evolved
and been acquired, and they're now part
of Synopsys.
I don't know if I knew that.
Okay.
So there was this division.
And it wasn't until considerably later, maybe
after the 2008 Great Recession, that some
of these companies said, you know, we
have all this work to do, and
our budgets have all been cut.
Let's go take a look at this
open source stuff, which is free.
And so that's what they did.
And so we saw, we began to
see gradual adoption of open source in
companies.
And this is that place where what
I was doing, evaluation and adoption of
open source, really became a central activity,
all these.
It took a long time.
And in fact, it's still in process.
But to get the analysts, the industry
analysts, like the partners of the world,
to when they do their evaluation, their
four quadrants.
The other quadrant, yeah.
So how do you get open source
software products into the upper quadrant?
Because otherwise, they'd be in the lower
left, right?
They don't have the structural
organization of the company, they don't have
the revenue, they don't have the roadmap,
they they don't have the support.
And so what turns out, as we
can say, looking backward, is that some
of the most successful open source companies
became that way by creating companies that
used that software.
So Drupal, for example, the founders of
Drupal set up a company called Acquia.
And Acquia provides a very good level
of hosting and commercial support for Drupal.
You have the same thing with Cassandra
and Hadoop, where there are companies that
provide that support.
But now to come back to your
question about open source and the OSI.
So the OSI, of course, was founded
in 1998.
And they had a board of directors.
And the board of directors, of course,
was started by Bruce Perens and by
Eric Raymond.
And what's his name from Red Hat?
Michael Tiemann.
Yes, thank you.
So Michael Tiemann, and then other people
were appointed.
And it was kind of a closed
system.
And in 2010, when they appointed new
members, invited to join and accepted.
And Simon Phipps also came out at
the same time as I did.
And Simon had been at Sun Microsystems.
But he has, these days, a very
successful open source consulting practice and does
some work for European governments and for
the UK government.
So a couple of things during our
tenure.
So I was on the board for
two terms, you know, I was termed
out, right?
That was the legal maximum.
But a few things happened.
First of all, Simon really drove the
idea of an affiliate program, so that
many of the other groups that were
doing open source software, and many of
the foundations doing open source software became
affiliates of the OSI.
So that, and that had the, you
know, that led to improved communication, and
it led to people being able to
represent open source more as a group
than as each individual foundation.
So getting and eventually, the affiliates, some
of them contributed money and money and
so one of the other good things
that happened is that we were able
to hire in the OSI, a general
manager.
And that was useful, because now you
had somebody whose job it was, primary
job was to represent the OSI.
Whereas the rest of us were, you
know, earning a living doing other things.
And another thing that happened during that
era was the creation of individual memberships.
Okay.
In the OSI.
Oh, right, where an organization could.
Right.
As you know, the Free Software Foundation
has individual members and the Linux Foundation
has individual members, and other groups as
well.
The OSI did not until about 2014,
maybe, not that long ago.
And there was not much of a
marketing program.
So they, you know, you'd have a
conference like the O'Reilly conference, where the
OSI would have a booth and, and
we tell people, you know, please, please
join.
We didn't have all that much to
give them in return.
The OSI didn't run its own conferences,
they didn't teach its own courses.
And so the OSI's main mission then
and now has been over license approval.
Right, right.
Yeah.
And so, and I think that's something
that not only has the OSI done,
done well, but that the, the open
source community as a whole, looks to
the OSI for its leadership and voice
on that.
Absolutely.
So if I understand the timeline,
correctly, you know, when you started, you
know, building that program around studying open
source adoption, that was prior to what
you kind of signaled as sort of
the more popular mainstream interest in open
source, like, it was prior to the
Great Recession, which you benchmark as kind
of a, that just tells me it's
sort of, you were on, you were
onto something, right, that you had an
inkling.
And I'm wondering what, what was it
about open source and about the idea
of open source?
What did you see at the time
that sparked your passion and curiosity to
pursue, build that program and pursue that?
It, you know, it just, it tells
me you had, you had insight into
something, right?
So there are a couple of things.
First of all,
in 2005, there was an effort started
called the Business Readiness Rating.
And, and it was started by SpikeSource,
which was a startup.
And the CEO of SpikeSource was Kim
Polese, who was the first product manager
for Java at Sun.
They, all these pieces eventually come back
together.
Yeah, Yeah, right, right, right, right, right.
And, and then the, there was funding
from Intel, a guy named Pete Kronowit,
who has since left computing to be
a musician.
And, and O'Reilly, Nat forget his last
name.
Anyway, Nat was the representative from O'Reilly,
so that, and then me.
So the, the four groups created this
Business Readiness Rating.
And as you can imagine, this is
right up my alley of evaluation and
adoption.
What makes a piece of open source
software ready to be used in a
business environment, whether that's commercial distribution of
the software, or inclusion of that software
in a product that they ship, or
whether it's internal use.
So what we did was we came
out with a set of evaluation criteria.
Initially, there were a dozen of them.
And that was a way that you
could look at a piece of open
source software and score it on these
criteria, documentation, the quality of the code,
the existence of some kind of a
process for reviewing bugs.
All these kinds of things could be
scored on a zero to five scale,
and you could add up all the
numbers and weight them.
But it turned out, when you think
about it, that you didn't have to
do a lot of work to know
which ones were really ready for commercial
use, because the ones that were the
most ready were the ones that already
provided the same kind of customer support
and updates and roadmaps that companies and
businesses expected from commercial software.
So if you made your open source
software business look like a commercial software
business, only here's the code too, you
had a much higher business readiness rating
score than if it was two graduate
students who were releasing new versions of
the software whenever it pleased them.
Coming in little mailers and shipping them
out of their apartment or
something, yeah.
Exactly.
So the business readiness rating was a
good idea, but we didn't
build automated tools to let you say,
here's this piece of software, go evaluate
it for, you can only evaluate part
of it because other things, you had
to go, for example, look on Amazon
and say, well, how many books are
written about this particular piece of software?
Oh, so what happened, first of all,
is that the guy who was the
main spike source contributor is Murugan Pal,
and he got sick and he's no
longer with us.
He died maybe a decade ago.
And Nat from O'Reilly went home to
New Zealand, and Pete Cronenweth from Intel
had other things he wanted to do.
So it kind of disintegrated, and it
actually stayed moribund, if you will, for
a number of years.
And then maybe if you will, for
And then maybe around 2012 or 13,
I said, well, this is a good
idea, so let's bring it back to
life and let's fix some of the
things that we need to do.
So first of all, we gave the
new project a name, and the name
is OSS Pal.
And Pal is obviously a double entendre,
one as an acknowledgement to Murugan Pal
and the other, that it's your pal.
Yeah, yep, yep.
It's your open source software.
So I love the name.
And the other thing we did in
the OSS Pal project, it was up
for many years on on OSSPal.org, but
no longer is maintained, it's not there.
So instead, if you go out and
do a search for, let's say, content
management systems, or even management systems, or
even open source content management systems, you're
going to get some huge number of
hits.
So if I'm some huge number of
So if I'm in, if I'm some
engineer in some company, and I say,
well, I want to go try one
of these open one of these open
source content management systems, and you go
to your favorite search engine, and you
type you go to your favorite search
engine, and you type you go to
your favorite search engine, and you type
you go to your favorite search engine,
and you type in open source content
management systems, you know, this wave.
Yep.
Like 1400 of them.
I can only imagine.
Yep.
Yeah.
And so we said, yeah, that's never
going to work.
So what we decided to do with
OSSPal, and I think it's it's really
a sound idea.
And if I had the resources, we
bring it all back to life.
As we curated, we said, look, you
know, what we know from our previous
experiences, there's certain things that you need
to have in a project for it
to be suitable for business use.
So we could go in there and
look at Drupal, for example, and say,
ah, okay, well, there's a company that
supports it, there's an ecosystem around it,
there's a big community.
It's been around for a while, there's
a roadmap, there are new releases, all
these things that make it attractive to
people who would be evaluating software.
So, you know, that makes the bar.
So what we would do was to
find candidates that people would want to
look at.
So rather than our saying to you,
use this content management system, we use
this database management system, we would say,
here are three or five candidates that
we think you should look at.
And then they could put weights for
the different criteria.
Some of those criteria were based on
the domain in which the software works.
So you ask different things in evaluating
a database management system than you do
in evaluating a content management system.
Does this take you back at all
to that dissertation project about, you know?
Not really, no.
No, but here are these criteria that
you're going to use.
And so we would pick several of
them.
And we worked with IDC, the analyst
company.
And IDC, it turns out, every year
publishes a software taxonomy.
And their software taxonomy breaks all of
software into categories.
And there are about 80 categories that
they identify.
Was it a perfect fit for open
source?
Not entirely, because a lot of the
open source projects that were most widely
used were developer tools and infrastructure, much
less the application side.
But it was a good starting point.
And we tried adding some additional application
domains so we could divide up development
tools, for example.
So we went ahead with that.
And the idea was, okay, we're going
to do the curation.
Now what we want is we get
these evaluations partly on the basis of
the domain, and partly in general, right?
How much documentation is there?
Is there the kind of generic things
that you might ask about any piece
of software?
So the idea then was that people
would write reviews.
Okay, so I've used Mozilla Firefox, okay?
And here's how I would evaluate it.
The same way you would evaluate a
movie or a restaurant or much of
anything else, give it, you know, a
bunch of check marks or scores, 05
in these different categories, and then free
text.
And, you know, we had the same
issue that all online surveys have, which
is that, how do you know that
the person who's writing the review is
being accurate about it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's not much you can do about
that, other than asking people to register
and get their email address and verify
it.
But we really didn't have the resources
to do the kind of awareness generation,
not to say marketing, that it would
take to bring a lot of people
in to write these reviews.
So we concluded that it was a
great idea, and that if we were
doing it as a commercial venture and
could raise venture capital to build it,
it would be valuable.
What's happened in the meantime is, of
course, the STARS mechanism that exists on
GitHub.
There's always been, or at least there's
been for a long time, OpenHub, which
lets you look at the source code,
and the contributions, and the dates, and
the, let's say, the aliveness of a
particular project.
So there's some other things that are
out there that play a valuable role
in terms of helping people evaluate open
source software.
And, of course, more and more with
commercial open source, you have salespeople.
And you have conferences like the Open
Source Summit that the Linux Foundation puts
on several times a year around the
world, and those have exhibit booths.
And so that's an opportunity for these
commercial businesses to tell the world about
their products.
Well, the final question I wanted to
ask you was about what you see
as
the biggest challenges for open source as
an idea, or for open source as
a movement, or even as a set
of practices in the future.
Now and in the future, what you
see is the largest potential impediments to
its proliferation or growth.
And I wonder if that's, is that
one of them, curation, you see as
a challenge or an issue?
Well, there are a lot of issues,
of course.
And, you know, answering this would depend
on how much time we have.
But the first part of it is
that proprietary software isn't going away.
Okay, that, you know, there are these
pipe dreams that some people have had
about, you know, the world going to
open source.
And, you know, I simply don't see
Oracle giving away their source code, or
other companies with such a major investment.
Now, Microsoft did a bit of that
when they did Visual Studio Code, above
what was in Visual Studio Pro, I
think, and made that freely available.
And there's some other examples of it.
But I think open source and proprietary
software are going to to coexist.
And I think that over time, as
more people come into the industry, they're
going to do their evaluations based on
functionality of the product, rather than, oh,
it's open, or it's closed, or here's
how much it costs.
I mean, that those become factors in
doing evaluation.
Another thing is that open source has
not been very strong, for example, in
mobile.
So when you start to look at
all the applications that have been developed
for mobile devices, you you know, you
put the F Droid library, which is
the Android mobile app, you put that
up against Google's Play Store.
And it's a joke.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
And, and Apple, in their store, you
know, makes it very difficult to get
open source software in there.
So there's not, there's not much of
it there.
So there are some definite challenges to
that.
And, you know, there's still this educational
process of how do you make money
at open source.
And now I teach open source software,
I've taught it, you know, 17 times
or something at Carnegie Mellon.
And it's evolved over the years, of
course, has brought guests in to share
their experience and knowledge.
But you know, there's still people who
don't believe, yeah, why would you write
software for free?
Yeah.
And, and my answer to them is,
well, why would you go volunteer your
time at the hospital to help six
people, sick people?
Why would you go to a place
where there's been a natural disaster and
do your best to help out?
These are, you know, things that people
do, because it gives them personal fulfillment.
So, so I think that there are
good answers to the question of why
do people do this for free?
Is that is that is the future
of open source beholden to people's altruism?
Like, is, is the limit of open
source, the limit of people's altruism, do
you think?
I don't know.
You know, it's, it's, you know, if
I were able to predict the future
that well, then I would be, I
would be very wealthy.
And I would be, I would be
like rich, Richard Branson on my own
island.
We probably wouldn't have been working for
so many failed startups, I guess, if
you could.
You You know, startups fail.
I, you know, I taught startup creation
kinds of things
at Carnegie Mellon.
And every now and then one of
the companies goes beyond the campus and
starts their own business.
But it's, there are a lot of
barriers to success.
And it's not until you're out there
doing it.
I work these days with Berkeley's accelerator
called Skydeck.
And they, they had like 1000 applicants
for 18 places, or, you know, some
key, wildly selective thing.
And then, and then we meet these
companies.
And, you know, a few of them
make it, right?
Because everything falls into place at the
right time.
But most of them, most of them
struggle.
And that's true of startups.
And it's been true as long as
the field has existed.
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
Well, this has been a wonderful way
to spend an afternoon.
And I really appreciate your time.
Thanks for sharing your thoughts.
Thanks for sharing your memories.
And, and, you know, this, this, as
we construct this great kind of oral
history of open source.
It's just been wonderful.
And I'm very grateful.
Oh, it's been it's been my pleasure.
And it forced me to recollect some
of these things and to dig some
of these names out of the far
reaches of my memory.
It's definitely good to have it down
there.
And I'll want to see the the
final version of it and, and perhaps
post on my LinkedIn.
Great.
Where, where this is all gone.
So, so that's great.